vaccine eligibility is expanding here in
nevada starting next week
on monday anyone 16 and older will be
eligible to receive the covet 19 vaccine
and this morning senators jackie rosen
and catherine cortez-masto made a visit
to a major vaccination site here in las
vegas
our bianca holman reports
moderna pfizer and johnson johnson kova
19 vaccines are all given here at the
cashman center
it's an example of the coordinated
effort between federal
state and local authorities senators
rosen and cortez masto got a look inside
at the site
escorted by leaders from the health
district fire department and
fema those who were vaccinated in the
observation
section listened to the henderson
symphony and spoke with the senators
people shared their good and bad moments
during the pandemic
one woman experiencing job loss and a
first-time father raising a baby
these senators say vaccines are
essential not only to save lives but
also to get our economy back on track
this site is proof to our
travelers that want to come back to las
vegas that we want
those over what 50 million visitors that
we're safe and we can do this safely
we can do it safely here we can work
with our properties we can work with our
businesses
to really make sure people feel
comfortable and safe the vaccine is free
of charge but you must make an
appointment
our state's timeline to make the vaccine
available to all adults is in line and
ahead of president joe biden's challenge
to have vaccines available for all
adults by may 1st
and you can make an appointment to
receive the covet 19 vaccine on the
southern nevada health district's
website
bialcoholman 8 news now